programming throwdown episode 84 customer bug handling dig it away jason hello hey everybody Jason. Hello. Hey, everybody. How's it going? Episode 84. This is going to be pretty interesting. I'm actually pretty excited about this. This is something that a lot of people, they don't really teach that well in school, and you could easily kind of get bitten by this. And I've definitely gotten bitten by it. And so we get to kind of talk about it. But before we do that, let's talk about some really funny computer science pop culture. So how many of you have seen some type of TV show, especially earlier on, like, let's say the 90s, early 2000s, and they talk they try to talk about computers and computer science is just such an epic fail.
Programming Throwdown 第 84 期，客户 Bug 处理，深入探讨，Jason 你好，嘿，大家好，Jason，你好，嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？第 84 期，这一期会非常有趣，我其实对此感到非常兴奋，这是学校里不太会教的内容，而且你很容易因此吃亏，我绝对吃过亏，所以我们来聊聊这个话题，但在那之前，先聊聊一些非常有趣的计算机科学流行文化，你们有多少人看过那种电视节目，尤其是早期的，比如 90 年代或 21 世纪初，他们试图谈论计算机和计算机科学，结果却是一场史诗级的失败。
We posted a few of them here. My favorite is and definitely check out the website Programming ThrowThrowdown.com, and you can check this out. But just spoilers here. The first one, they're trying to track some criminal hacker, and this woman's like, he's doing it in real time. And then this other lady goes, I'm gonna write a GUI in Visual Basic to track his IP address dead serious and then she
我们在这里发布了一些，我最喜欢的是，一定要去看看 ProgrammingThrowdown.com 网站，你可以去看看，但这里先剧透一下，第一个片段里，他们试图追踪某个犯罪黑客，这个女人说，他正在实时操作，然后另一个女士说，我要用 Visual Basic 写一个 GUI 来追踪他的 IP 地址，一本正经的样子，然后她
just walks away and i'm pretty sure yeah at the end of the movie they yeah that that gui saves the day but uh it's pretty epic and then there's uh there's a couple other ones definitely check them out on the website um yeah who is this 4chan guy and uh that's another good one um if you have any good ones send them over to us um but it's just it's no end of entertainment there um people have now even made playlists there's whole playlists of all just hacking uh uh you know hacking video fails um one other thing to mention a lot of people wrote in about our last episode, which was the episode on teaching kids to code. And let me pull it up right now. There were some actually absolutely phenomenal suggestions out there.
就走开了，我很确定，是的，在电影结尾，那个 GUI 拯救了世界，但这太史诗了，还有其他几个片段，一定要去网站上看看，嗯，这个 4chan 是谁，这是另一个好玩的，如果你有好的素材，发给我们，那里有无穷无尽的娱乐，人们甚至制作了播放列表，全是关于黑客视频的失败集锦，还有一件事要提，很多人写信给我们关于上一期节目，也就是教孩子编程的那一期，让我现在把它调出来，那里有一些绝对非常棒的建议。
While you pull that up, I'll give my contribution to this, which is I have nothing to say on computer science references, but I know this is a thing that other people talk about as well. Like I've seen YouTube videos from a biologist saying biology and video and movies is all wrong. Astrophysics is all wrong. I think Neil deGrasse Tyson does some about like space travel and astrophysics and ruins movies, you know, by, by pointing out how bad the plot is. And the one, one I saw recently was people complaining about, like, how you learn jazz music. So I think this is a universal thing where movies try to take artistic liberty
在你调出来的时候，我也贡献一下，我对计算机科学的引用没什么可说的，但我知道这是其他人也会谈论的事情，就像我看到过生物学家说生物学在视频和电影里全是错的，天体物理学也全是错的，我想 Neil deGrasse Tyson 做过一些关于太空旅行和天体物理学的节目，通过指出情节有多糟糕来毁掉电影，你知道，我最近看到的一个是人们抱怨学习爵士乐的方式，所以我认为这是一个普遍现象，电影试图采取艺术自由
because you want to make an interesting movie. And personally, people are like, oh, they don't know what they're doing. They're so dumb. But I don't know. I think personally it's just they might know or they could go figure it out. out like i'm gonna make a visual basic gui to hack his ip address yeah sure that doesn't actually make sense but to 99.9 of people that sounds the equivalent of avada kedavra it's like oh yeah you're just making harry potter spells like it's just an incantation they don't need it they're picking real words but it doesn't have to be meaningful yeah that totally makes sense yeah i think uh i wonder i wonder uh if now because
因为你想拍一部有趣的电影，个人而言，人们会说，哦，他们不知道自己在做什么，他们太蠢了，但我不知道，我觉得他们可能知道，或者他们可以去查，比如我要做一个 Visual Basic GUI 来黑进他的 IP 地址，是的，当然，这实际上说不通，但对 99.9% 的人来说，这听起来就像是“阿瓦达索命”，就像哦，是的，你只是在念哈利波特咒语，这就像一个咒语，他们不需要它，他们只是在选真实的词，但它不需要有意义，是的，这完全说得通，是的，我想，我想知道现在是否因为
i feel like nowadays they're a bit better about that so so i wonder if they maybe they consult with somebody it's just that when these shows were made you know that was so kind of unpopular and passe that they just made stuff up because nowadays it seems much more legit like when i watch more recent shows that's right and i think even in um so i think famously in the die hard movie the bad guy is oh i'm not forgetting it either german or russian and he's that's what they insinuate but he's just speaking i think just gibberish and in the sort of german and russian version you know whatever it is the bad guy is some other country but he's speaking the same words because they're just sort of like gibberish words i believe i'm recalling this correctly but then
我觉得现在他们在这方面做得好一点了，所以我怀疑他们可能咨询了某人，只是当这些节目制作时，你知道，那太不受欢迎且过时了，所以他们只是编造了一些东西，因为现在看起来更正规了，当我看最近的节目时，确实如此，而且我认为甚至在《虎胆龙威》电影中，坏人是，哦，我也没忘，德国人还是俄国人，这就是他们暗示的，但他只是在说，我想只是胡言乱语，在某种德语和俄语版本中，你知道，无论是什么，坏人是另一个国家，但他说的词是一样的，因为它们只是某种胡言乱语，我相信我没记错，但后来
someone was pointing out that uh in like game of thrones they actually like consulted there's like a guy who's the hollywood consultant for foreign languages or invented languages he's like a linguist oh and so like in game of thrones this this darth vackie language or whatever is actually modeled after realistic languages it didn't and it's how it's a whole language it's a whole thing and when they need a new word or sentence structure that they've not had before they like consult with him and he like helps them come up with like a cohesive system as if it really were a language wow that's cool yeah i uh i think i recently saw um the show scandal and uh um yeah my wife was watching it and i was catching a couple episodes and um yeah they had some hacking sequence and it kind of made sense i mean it wasn't
有人指出，在《权力的游戏》中，他们实际上咨询了某人，有一个人是好莱坞的外语或发明语言顾问，他是个语言学家，哦，所以在《权力的游戏》中，这种多斯拉克语或什么的，实际上是模仿现实语言建模的，它不是，它是一整门语言，是一整套东西，当他们需要一个新的词或句子结构时，他们以前没用过，他们就会咨询他，他会帮助他们想出一个连贯的系统，就好像它真的是一门语言一样，哇，那太酷了，是的，我最近看了《丑闻》这部剧，我妻子在看，我看了几集，嗯，他们有一些黑客场景，它有点道理，我的意思是它不是
i i don't know much about hacking myself but i mean it definitely seemed a little like out of place like but but you know they had a bash command and they're doing you know i don't ls and they're going to a directory and looking at a file i was like it was it was much better than the ones we posted but also much less funny um but yeah as far as teaching kids to code um anthony wrote in he had a ton of really amazing resources. One of them, which I actually have for my kid, but I forgot, is Kano. I don't know. Do you have a Kano kit?
我对自己了解的黑客技术不多，但它看起来确实有点格格不入，但你知道，他们有一个 bash 命令，他们在做 ls，他们进入一个目录并查看一个文件，我觉得这比我们发布的那些要好得多，但也少了很多乐趣，但就教孩子编程而言，Anthony 写信来了，他有很多非常棒的资源，其中一个我实际上为我的孩子准备了，但我忘了，是 Kano，我不知道，你有 Kano 套件吗？
No. Or have you heard of this? So it's like this. It looks like about a Raspberry Pi with a case, maybe a little bit bigger than that. But it has like a little joystick built right onto the onto the motherboard and the joystick kind of pops out of the case and it's also got some buttons and um you could just they have like uh snakes and a couple of simple games but you actually have to build the computer yourself um you don't have to solder or anything crazy but but uh you know the you have to plug
没有，或者你听说过这个吗？所以它就像这样，看起来像一个带外壳的树莓派，可能比那个大一点，但它在主板上内置了一个小操纵杆，操纵杆从外壳里弹出来，它还有一些按钮，你可以，他们有像贪吃蛇和几个简单的游戏，但你实际上必须自己组装电脑，你不需要焊接或做任何疯狂的事情，但你必须插入
the battery in you have to actually plug the buttons in um you have to kind of assemble the case and everything um so that was when he mentioned um also scratch that's pretty popular it's like a little graphical programming language um and then betty wrote in and um betty's actually a math professor at actually i won't say the university just in case i don't really know if people like mine does, you know, revealing their identity or not. But but anyways, with that in mind, I would say where she teaches, but she's a math professor and she recommended something called Bricklayer.org, which looks really cool. So she actually founded it and it looks like it has a bunch of different things for um you're using lego um to teach kids math and things like that so some really cool resources i was actually really impressed that a math professor even even listens to the show so
电池，你必须实际插入按钮，你必须组装外壳等等，所以这就是他提到的，还有 Scratch，那很受欢迎，它像一个小型的图形化编程语言，然后 Betty 写信来了，Betty 实际上是一位数学教授，我不会说出大学名字，以防万一，我真的不知道人们是否像我一样，介意透露他们的身份，但无论如何，考虑到这一点，我会说她在哪里教书，但她是一位数学教授，她推荐了一个叫 Bricklayer.org 的网站，看起来真的很酷，她实际上创立了它，看起来它有很多不同的东西，用于你使用乐高来教孩子数学之类的，所以一些非常酷的资源，我实际上印象非常深刻，一位数学教授竟然也听这个节目，所以
kudos to you uh betty and uh and also anthony thanks for the thanks for the heads up all right man is it time for news? Links? I think so. I completely lost. Do you want to do the first one? For some reason, I totally lost mine. Okay, no problem.
向你致敬，Betty，还有 Anthony，谢谢你的提醒，好了伙计，是时候聊新闻了吗？链接？我想是的，我完全忘了，你想做第一个吗？出于某种原因，我完全忘了我的。好的，没问题。
All right, so the first one I have is running across an article about using, which apparently is built into both Excel and Google Sheets, but using the Google online version of Google, of Excel, the spreadsheet application, is being able to run simple SQL-like queries in it. I find it very difficult sometimes that I want to do something, and there almost always is a way to do it, of manipulating or filtering or searching for data. And so this points out that you can do some common SQL operations within a column in the spreadsheet. Do you have to install something? No, no, I'm built in. It does not let you do joins, but it does allow for filtering. like sort of to me like the group by clause the you know min of something group by order by this
好的，第一个是我偶然发现的一篇文章，关于使用 Excel 和 Google Sheets 中内置的功能，但使用 Google 在线版本的 Excel，电子表格应用程序，能够在其中运行简单的类似 SQL 的查询，我有时觉得很难，我想做某事，几乎总有一种方法可以做到，操作、过滤或搜索数据，所以这指出你可以在电子表格的列中执行一些常见的 SQL 操作，你需要安装什么吗？不，不，内置的，它不允许你做连接，但它允许过滤，对我来说就像 group by 子句，某物的最小值，按此分组，按此排序
is more in not honestly intuitive is the right word but it's more at hand to me because i've done that more recently uh yeah and so i'll link this but this is from ben collins uh and so he there's some videos linkedin even as well to be fair i honestly didn't watch the videos but i just looked at the examples and sort of got the gist and so you can sort of say equals query the column you want you know select this other column this other column this other column where you know the whole the whole thing so that was pretty cool i didn't had no idea and then you know apparently it's also there's some stuff that works in excel so if you ever find yourself needing to use spreadsheets i find is one of those weird things there are many many many people who spend enormous amounts of time in spreadsheets
这对我来说更直观，不是说直观是正确的词，但它更顺手，因为我最近做得更多，是的，我会链接这个，这是来自 Ben Collins 的，所以他有一些视频，甚至还有 LinkedIn，公平地说，我老实说没看视频，但我只是看了例子并大致了解了要点，所以你可以说等于查询你想要的列，你知道，选择这一列，那一列，那一列，其中，你知道，整个事情，所以这很酷，我完全不知道，然后显然它在 Excel 中也有一些东西可以使用，所以如果你发现自己需要使用电子表格，我发现这是那些奇怪的事情之一，有很多人在电子表格上花费了大量时间
and really know what they're doing when it's like a python program probably could have done this way easier but it's just what they're comfortable with. But on the flip side, I find a lot of times... I think the GUI for Excel is just amazing. Like the user experience is so nice. I'm really surprised that more languages don't have something like Excel where you can kind of just easily see everything and things like that.
并且真正知道他们在做什么，而 Python 程序可能更容易做到这一点，但这只是他们习惯的东西，但另一方面，我发现很多时候……我觉得 Excel 的 GUI 太棒了，用户体验非常好，我真的很惊讶没有更多的语言有像 Excel 那样的东西，你可以很容易地看到所有东西等等。
And I will say that for me, people from a CS background though, I think sometimes underutilize, of just easily see everything and you know things like that yeah and i will say that for me people from a cs background though i think sometimes underutilize i guess you're sort of alluding to the same thing but people from a cs background tend to underutilize spreadsheets um because sometimes it really is fast just to dump a bunch of data into a csv open it up in excel google sheets uh the open office i'm not sure what it's called their number no no no numbers is the um in Excel, Google Sheets, the OpenOffice. I'm not sure what it's called there. Numbers?
我会说，对于我来说，来自 CS 背景的人，我觉得有时利用不足，可以很容易地看到所有东西等等，是的，我会说，对于我来说，来自 CS 背景的人，我觉得有时利用不足，我想你是在暗示同样的事情，但来自 CS 背景的人往往利用不足电子表格，因为有时把一堆数据转储到 CSV 中，在 Excel、Google Sheets 中打开它，OpenOffice，我不确定它叫什么，Numbers，不，不，Numbers 是 macOS 版本。
No, Numbers is the macOS version. Yeah, there's LibreOffice, which is a fork of OpenOffice. That's the only one I know. Yeah, but they have a spreadsheet equivalent, but I don't know what the name of it is in that suite. Do you know? Okay. Oh, I think it's just called Sheets.
不，Numbers 是 macOS 版本，是的，有 LibreOffice，它是 OpenOffice 的一个分支，这是我唯一知道的，是的，但他们有一个电子表格等价物，但我不知道那个套件里它的名字是什么，你知道吗？好的，哦，我想它就叫 Sheets。
I could look it up. Okay, it doesn't matter. And any of those. Anyways, dumping a CSV, opening them up in there, and being able's just called Sheets. I can look it up. Okay, it doesn't matter. And any of those. Anyways, dumping a CSV, opening them up in there, and being able to do something really quick, depending on your data processing skills in Python, may or may not be faster. With stuff like Jupyter Notebooks and Pandas,
我可以查一下，好的，没关系，无论哪一个，总之，转储一个 CSV，在里面打开它们，能够，它就叫 Sheets，我可以查一下，好的，没关系，无论哪一个，总之，转储一个 CSV，在里面打开它们，能够做一些非常快的事情，取决于你在 Python 中的数据处理技能，可能比这更快，也可能不比这更快，有了 Jupyter Notebooks 和 Pandas 之类的东西，
that story is becoming slightly less awesome if you know how to use those tools. They can often be almost as effective. Okay. But yeah, anyways, if you, if you do know how to use this or stuck with some data in that format,
如果你知道如何使用这些工具，那个故事就变得不那么令人惊叹了，它们通常几乎一样有效，好的，但无论如何，如果你知道如何使用它，或者被困在那种格式的数据中，
check it out. Yeah. It sounds awesome. Yeah. Actually the, the there's our studio and that's the only thing. I mean, I guess MATLAB,
去看看，是的，听起来很棒，实际上，有 RStudio，这是唯一的东西，我的意思是，我想 MATLAB，
right. I think MATLAB has a little spreadsheet type thing, but I guess um that's that's kind of like a sledgehammer right there really isn't a good you know if you want um excel that excel style where you just have all of your matrices are just completely visualized like that like in those sheets um there's really there's really nothing out there i'm actually shocked well actually isn't there uh there are some products i've just never used them there's tableau and um yeah there's there's another one i can't remember the name of it but i think people have done this it's just none of them have have have gotten any popularity all right that's super cool i'll have to try that out. My news is about decentralization
对，我想 MATLAB 有一个小型的电子表格之类的东西，但我猜那就像一把大锤，真的没有一个好的，如果你想要 Excel 那种风格，你所有的矩阵都完全可视化，就像在那些表格里一样，真的没有什么东西，我实际上很震惊，好吧，其实没有吗？有一些产品，我只是从没用过它们，有 Tableau，还有另一个，我不记得名字了，但我认为人们已经做到了，只是它们都没有流行起来，好的，那太酷了，我得试试，我的新闻是关于去中心化
issues or sorry, deserialization issues. So a lot of people might not have tried this, but in Python, you have pickle. And in Java, you have, I can't remember, I think it's just called the Java serializer. And you have similar things in Ruby and things like that. And it's pretty amazing. Like in Python, you can actually, you know, you can pickle anything. So any, almost any object, if you try to pickle, let's say a file pointer or something like that, you'll get a, you'll get an error, but you could pickle almost any object without having to write any serialization code. Like you don't have to, you know, do a, like, like concatenate a bunch of fields into a string and then figure out how to pull them back apart. It just does the deserialization for you. The
问题，或者抱歉，反序列化问题，所以很多人可能没试过这个，但在 Python 中，你有 pickle，在 Java 中，你有，我不记得了，我想它就叫 Java 序列化器，你在 Ruby 之类的语言中也有类似的东西，这非常神奇，比如在 Python 中，你实际上可以，你知道，你可以 pickle 任何东西，所以任何，几乎任何对象，如果你尝试 pickle，比如一个文件指针之类的，你会得到一个错误，但你可以 pickle 几乎任何对象，而无需编写任何序列化代码，比如你不需要，你知道，把一堆字段连接成一个字符串，然后想办法把它们拆开，它直接为你做反序列化。
serialization does everything for you. And it writes it to some binary file. So it seems kind of like magic. It seems really cool. The thing about is it's so open ended that, well that well for one it's not very efficient so a lot of people don't really use it other than kind of you know prototyping and things like that also the language upgrade so if you go to from python 2 to python 3 that could cause some issues but on top of that there's some real security vulnerabilities and so i think that's again comes back to the whole like fact that you could you could pickle almost anything so there's actually a way where um and you'll have to read the article to get the details but i think at a high level what's going on is you know you unpickle something and it unpickles into uh or basically someone has created, so you pickle a file and then you unpickle it
序列化为你做了一切，它把它写成某种二进制文件，所以看起来有点像魔法，看起来真的很酷，关于它的事情是它太开放了，好吧，首先它效率不高，所以很多人除了原型设计之类的之外并不真正使用它，还有语言升级，所以如果你从 Python 2 升级到 Python 3，那可能会导致一些问题，但除此之外，还有一些真正的安全漏洞，所以我认为这又回到了这样一个事实，你可以 pickle 几乎任何东西，所以实际上有一种方法，你需要阅读文章来了解细节，但我认为在高层面上发生的事情是，你知道，你反序列化某物，它反序列化成，或者基本上有人创建了，所以你 pickle 一个文件，然后你反序列化它
later to get back your object, right? But let's say someone has access to that file and they can manipulate it or replace it with another file. Then you unpickle it and, you know, thinking that it's the original file and then just start using that class. But it turns out that person has kind of poisoned it so for example um just a really naive example let's say you could just pickle lambda functions so you could pickle a whole function with all the operations and so you know you have various you have dot x
稍后取回你的对象，对吧？但假设有人可以访问该文件，他们可以操纵它或用另一个文件替换它，然后你反序列化它，你知道，认为它是原始文件，然后就开始使用那个类，但事实证明那个人已经把它毒化了，所以例如，只是一个非常天真的例子，假设你可以只 pickle lambda 函数，所以你可以 pickle 整个函数以及所有操作，所以你知道，你有各种，你有 dot x
equals three so you have class my class dot x equals three you pickle my class and so that file now says okay my class had an object x and it was an integer of three now someone comes along and replaces that file with one that says oh yeah my class had a variable called x and it was actually a function that you know wipes your hard drive and then later on you de-pickle that, unpickle that, and then call, you know, myclass.x and, and you, and you lose your hard drive, right? So, so, I mean, I don't think it's that simple, but, but at a high level, that's kind of what's going on is someone can actually inject really dangerous code. And when you, when you unpickle, you get, you get hit by that. But it's a cool article. They actually, they, they linked to some by that. But it's a cool article.
等于 3，所以你有 class my class dot x 等于 3，你 pickle my class，所以那个文件现在说，好的，my class 有一个对象 x，它是一个整数 3，现在有人过来用一个文件替换了那个文件，上面写着哦，是的，my class 有一个叫 x 的变量，它实际上是一个函数，你知道，会擦除你的硬盘，然后稍后你反序列化它，然后调用，你知道，myclass.x，然后你，你失去了你的硬盘，对吧？所以，我的意思是，我不认为有那么简单，但从高层面上看，这就是正在发生的事情，有人实际上可以注入非常危险的代码，当你反序列化时，你会被它击中，但这篇很酷的文章，他们实际上链接到一些
They actually link to some other articles. So it's a bit of a rabbit hole, but you can follow the rabbit hole down to some really good presentations where people talk about it in detail. And they show you, they walk you through examples of how exactly this can happen. And yeah, I just found this stuff fascinating. It's an attack vector that I didn't really realize was the thing until just now. Yeah, serialization and deserialization are tricky and important to get right, especially if other people are providing you data. Yeah, exactly.
他们实际上链接到其他文章，所以这有点像兔子洞，但你可以顺着兔子洞找到一些非常好的演示文稿，人们在那里详细讨论它，他们向你展示，引导你通过例子，确切地说明这怎么可能发生，是的，我只是觉得这些东西很迷人，这是一个我直到现在才意识到存在的攻击向量，是的，序列化和反序列化很棘手，而且必须正确处理，特别是如果其他人为你提供数据。是的，完全正确。
Yeah, I mean, anytime someone else is contributing data, you have to really expect just about anything. I have no idea why you would use pickle for data that's coming from other people i actually maybe it's because you're unpickling crash logs in which case that might not be the right tool for that job so on a similar related topic i ran across i actually think this i got this on the programming uh subreddit the stack sort a la xkcd so there was an xkcd oh i should have brought it up so i could link that as well um there was an xkcd article where they described an ineffective sort and one of the ineffective sorts is it here uh no there was one where they
是的，我的意思是，任何时候其他人提供数据，你真的必须预料到几乎任何事情，我不知道为什么你会对来自其他人的数据使用 pickle，我实际上，也许是因为你在反序列化崩溃日志，在这种情况下，那可能不是该工作的正确工具，所以在一个相关的话题上，我偶然发现，我实际上认为这是我在编程 subreddit 上看到的，Stack Sort，类似 XKCD，所以有一个 XKCD，我应该把它调出来，这样我也可以链接它，有一篇 XKCD 文章，他们描述了一种无效的排序，其中一种无效的排序是它在这里吗？不，有一个地方他们
basically alluded to let me see if i can find it that they alluded to uh searching for a sorting algorithm oh here it is perfect linked i should have just gone to the github page no it is there so basically uh like crappy the xkcd was showing crappy ways to do various sorts. So things like, you know, pick a random number. And then at some point, like run various commands, like rm-rf star, you know, do just like crazy things. It was just sort of a joke, right? Like XKCD stuff. So this person tried to say, oh, I know of a joke right like xkd cd xkcd stuff so this person tried to say oh i i know of
基本上暗示了，让我看看能不能找到它，他们暗示了搜索排序算法，哦，在这里，完美链接，我应该直接去 GitHub 页面，不，它在那里，所以基本上，像 crappy，XKCD 展示了各种排序的糟糕方法，所以像，你知道，选一个随机数，然后在某个点，运行各种命令，比如 rm-rf star，你知道，做一些疯狂的事情，这只是一个玩笑，对吧？像 XKCD 的东西，所以这个人试图说，哦，我知道
a way to do an ineffective sort we'll search stack overflow for how to sort a list in javascript and we'll run the example code like people put example code so we'll find top voted answers where there's code and then we'll try to run it and see if it sorts the list and so if you go to the website uh which is sort of a super sketch and even like says i'm gonna pull some scripts from stack overflow and eval them so like hey this is probably a really bad idea. You probably don't want to do this. But if you do, it goes and pulls it and then tries to see if it'll sort the list or not. So most of them turn out not to be runnable, but occasionally you'll run across one that will work.
一种做无效排序的方法，我们将搜索 Stack Overflow 如何在 JavaScript 中对列表进行排序，我们将运行示例代码，就像人们放示例代码一样，所以我们将找到高票答案，那里有代码，然后我们将尝试运行它，看看它是否对列表进行了排序，所以如果你去那个网站，它有点超级草率，甚至说我要从 Stack Overflow 拉取一些脚本并 eval 它们，所以嘿，这可能是一个非常糟糕的主意，你可能不想这样做，但如果你这样做，它会去拉取它，然后尝试看看它是否会对列表进行排序，所以大多数结果证明是不可运行的，但偶尔你会遇到一个能工作的。
And so you just keep running them until you find that it's sorted. And so of course you could check if it's sorted. And then, it's a little more clever though because the first immediately obvious thing is to just start upvoting an answer that does something very malicious like uploading all of your browser history or you know running a you wouldn't mind bitcoin but running a cryptocurrency miner in JavaScript. And so you could do something really crazy malicious. So what he did was limit it to posts that came out
所以你只是不断运行它们，直到你发现它排好序了，当然你可以检查它是否已排序，然后，它更聪明一点，因为第一个立即显而易见的事情是开始给一个做非常恶意的事情的答案点赞，比如上传你所有的浏览器历史记录，或者你知道，运行一个，你不会介意比特币，但在 JavaScript 中运行加密货币矿工，所以你可以做一些非常疯狂的恶意事情，所以他所做的是将其限制在那些发布的帖子
before he sort of pushed this up so that people wouldn't know that he was going to do that. Yeah, so it was at least somewhat thoughtful. So anyway, so I thought that was kind of like a good joke. Oh, that's what it was. My brain is not working this episode. I apologize in advance. So it was the alt text of the XKCD.
在他推送这个之前，这样人们就不会知道他要那样做，是的，所以它至少有点深思熟虑，所以无论如何，所以我认为那就像一个好笑话，哦，原来是这样，我的大脑这期节目没在工作，我提前道歉，所以那是 XKCD 的替代文本。
So if you don't, this is something I didn't know about for a long time. I guess I'm not enough of an enthusiast. So there's like XKCD Explains website, I think is what it's called, where they explain some of the jokes because sometimes it's not obvious even like to me but then a lot of times there's stuff when you hover over the image and it gives you the like explanation of what the image is supposed to be there's this alt text and a lot of times there's this funny alt text so the alt text of the ineffective sort page on xkcd is stack sort connects to stack overflow searches for sort a list downloads and runs the code snippets until it finds one that sorts the list that's what the is stack sort, connects to Stack Overflow, searches for sort a list,
所以如果你不知道，这是我很久以来都不知道的事情，我想我不是一个足够狂热的粉丝，所以有一个 XKCD Explains 网站，我想是叫这个名字，他们解释了一些笑话，因为有时即使对我来说也不明显，但很多时候当你把鼠标悬停在图像上时，它会给你解释图像应该是什么，有这个替代文本，很多时候有这个有趣的替代文本，所以 XKCD 上无效排序页面的替代文本是 Stack Sort 连接到 Stack Overflow，搜索对列表进行排序，下载并运行代码片段，直到找到一个对列表进行排序的，这就是
downloads and runs the code snippets until it finds one that sorts the list. That's what the alt text says. And this person implemented that. Sorry, I completely butchered the beginning of that story. But if you didn't know about this... It's amazing. You should absolutely try that. Or don't. Like, I'm not sure.
下载并运行代码片段，直到找到一个对列表进行排序的，这就是替代文本所说的，而这个人实现了这一点，抱歉，我完全搞砸了那个故事的开头，但如果你不知道这个……这太神奇了，你绝对应该试试，或者别试，我不确定。
Sounds immediately like a terrible, terrible thing to do. Yeah, mines of Bitcoin, sends it to Patrick, and then sorts the list. Takes a long time. I did notice, while we've mentioned Bitcoin now a couple times, that the number of times I overhear cryptocurrency being mentioned randomly while walking by has dropped very strongly correlated with the drop in price. Yeah, I mean, nobody's really talking about it anymore it's pretty wild actually um they started cracking down on the browser-based miners i saw that yeah yeah so there was an issue where um there were
听起来立即是一件非常非常糟糕的事情，是的，挖掘比特币，发送给 Patrick，然后对列表进行排序，需要很长时间，我确实注意到，虽然我们现在提到了几次比特币，但我走路时偶然听到加密货币被随机提及的次数已经大幅下降，与价格的下跌有很强的相关性，是的，我的意思是，没人再谈论它了，这实际上很疯狂，嗯，他们开始打击基于浏览器的矿工，我看到了，是的，是的，所以有一个问题，嗯，有
some websites that were um just mining cryptocurrency So you would go to the website and while you're on the website doing whatever you're doing on there, it's mining cryptocurrency. So one of the examples is actually BitChute, which we talked about in the past, which was a way to watch videos kind of like YouTube. They were running a cryptocurrency miner and they actually just they posted in their blog that they just turned it off because of pressure. I guess their ISP is going to shut them down or something. But up until now, they've been just mining Bitcoin on your computer, which is pretty wild. Yeah.
一些网站，嗯，只是在挖掘加密货币，所以你会去那个网站，当你在这个网站上做任何事情时，它正在挖掘加密货币，所以其中一个例子实际上是 BitChute，我们过去谈论过，这是一种观看视频的方式，有点像 YouTube，他们正在运行一个加密货币矿工，他们实际上只是，他们在博客上发布说他们因为压力刚刚关闭了它，我猜他们的 ISP 要关闭他们之类的，但直到现在，他们一直在你的电脑上挖掘比特币，这很疯狂，是的。
So I don't know. So the reason why I said not Bitcoin is because i think bitcoin from a cpu perspective is really bad now but there are other coins which are still like designed purposely to work pretty well in a cpu still um and so i'm not sure the exact details but i'm actually that falls into this is off topic i guess but it falls into a little bit of a murky thing because at some level it's like if i go to youtube and i'm watching a video for free, you can send advertisements. Or if you disclosed it properly, like not the whole time watching a video, but maybe for like the first 30 seconds that I'm watching a video, it's computing some hash, doing some work, whatever. And that's like the exchange for me being able to watch the video to like help offset the costs.
所以我不知道，所以我说不是比特币的原因是因为我认为从 CPU 的角度来看，比特币现在真的很糟糕，但还有其他硬币仍然像是有意设计成在 CPU 上仍然运行得很好，所以我不知道确切的细节，但我实际上，这属于，我想这是题外话，但它属于一个有点模糊的事情，因为在某种程度上，就像如果我去 YouTube 看免费视频，你可以发送广告，或者如果你适当地披露了它，不是一直看视频，而是可能在我看视频的前 30 秒，它正在计算一些哈希，做一些工作，无论什么，那就像我能够看视频以帮助抵消成本的交换。
Like at some level, it seems like it could be a reasonable business model the issue is just doing it without people's consent seems a little like slimy but i'm not clear why it became such a major issue i think if they had popped up a box saying you know you have to agree to mine bitcoin to watch this video i think it would be a totally different story yeah yeah i guess i yeah i don't know i don't know how i feel but people installing malware that does it on your computer like obviously like sucks right that's they're doing something completely without your permission and there were some malicious i believe chrome add-ons and other add-ons to browsers where people were doing it as well you know slipping them into well that was an article yesterday or two days ago
在某种程度上，这看起来可能是一个合理的商业模式，问题只是在没有人们同意的情况下这样做，看起来有点像卑鄙，但我不太清楚为什么它成为了一个主要问题，我想如果他们弹出一个框说，你知道，你必须同意挖掘比特币才能观看此视频，我想那将是一个完全不同的故事，是的，是的，我猜我，我不知道，我不知道我的感觉，但人们安装在你的电脑上做这件事的恶意软件，显然，很烂，对吧？那是他们在完全没有你许可的情况下做某事，而且我相信有一些恶意的 Chrome 插件和其他浏览器插件，人们也在做这件事，你知道，把它们塞进，嗯，那是昨天或两天前的一篇文章
where there was a node.js package that uh checked to see if you have a wallet on the computer and if it had a certain number of bitcoins it would get your private key and send it to a command and control uh server and this like node package was imported by lots of major uh projects um i mean that obviously like horrible right and or putting putting some sort of uh obfuscated crypto miner in a package that you manage as an open source thing without telling anybody like i think those things are all pretty bad but yeah in general i'm not it seems kind of like a decent trade you could make like i'll go to your website in exchange for donating some of my compute power yeah i mean it seems fine to me i mean as long as yeah as you said as long as the consent is handled correctly i mean i think it's fine all right my my show topic is a retrospective on GraphQL.
有一个 node.js 包，检查你电脑上是否有钱包，如果它有一定数量的比特币，它会获取你的私钥并将其发送到命令和控制服务器，这个 node 包被许多主要项目导入，我的意思是，这显然很可怕，对吧？或者在你不告诉任何人的情况下，在你管理的开源项目中放入某种混淆的加密矿工，我认为这些事情都很糟糕，但总的来说，我不是，这看起来像是一个你可以做的体面交易，比如我将去你的网站，以换取捐赠我的一些计算能力，是的，我的意思是，这对我来说看起来不错，我的意思是，只要，是的，正如你所说，只要同意处理得当，我的意思是，我认为这很好，好的，我的节目主题是关于 GraphQL 的回顾。
So we haven't actually talked a lot about GraphQL. I think GraphQL would definitely be a great show. And we should definitely, I'll add that to my list of things as I think about it. But just to kind of explain briefly GraphQL, It's a replacement for REST. So you typically have a REST API, and you'll have, for example, you have a bunch of endpoints. So if I go to my website, slash API slash me, it maybe returns some JSON with my information. If I go to slash API slash user, you know, question mark, you know, Patrick, then it gets his information if I have access to it or whatever. And so you could you could build endpoints like this. But things kind of especially for graph based information, it kind of gets out of control.
所以我们实际上还没有谈论太多关于 GraphQL，我认为 GraphQL 绝对会是一个很棒的节目，我们绝对应该，我会把它加到我的清单里，当我想到它的时候，但只是为了简要解释 GraphQL，它是 REST 的替代品，所以你通常有一个 REST API，你会，例如，你有一堆端点，所以如果我去我的网站，斜杠 API 斜杠 me，它可能返回一些带有我信息的 JSON，如果我去斜杠 API 斜杠 user，你知道，问号，你知道，Patrick，那么如果我有访问权限或什么的，它就会得到他的信息，所以你可以，你可以构建像这样的端点，但事情，特别是对于基于图的信息，它有点失控。
And it turns out a lot of things are are can be modeled in sort of a graph. So imagine you have email. So you have your inbox folders, and each of those folders have emails. Each of those emails have attachments. You can kind of see there's this sort of tree structure developing, right? And so you end up writing these really complicated query handlers for being able to return data.
事实证明，很多事情都可以建模成某种图，所以想象你有电子邮件，所以你有你的收件箱文件夹，每个文件夹都有电子邮件，每封电子邮件都有附件，你可以看到正在形成这种树结构，对吧？所以你最终编写了这些非常复杂的查询处理程序，以便能够返回数据。
And typically, you end up needing to access different slices of data at different times. And rather than write, you know, 10,000 query handlers, you end up writing one that returns more data than you actually need, just so that it can service, you know, three or four different requests or different types of requests. And it just gets very messy. And so GraphQL is basically a replacement for REST where you basically say, GraphQL, you know, you own, you know, this part of my website. So it's like, you know, slash API slash GraphQL, like everything in there is owned by GraphQL. And then what they will do is, is it's, it's just a, they will basically handle a lot of that for you. And so you can execute different queries and you can ask for,
通常，你最终需要在不同时间访问数据的不同切片，而不是编写，你知道，10,000 个查询处理程序，你最终编写一个返回比你实际需要更多数据的处理程序，只是为了让它能够服务，你知道，三四个不同的请求或不同类型的请求，它变得非常混乱，所以 GraphQL 基本上是 REST 的替代品，你基本上说，GraphQL，你知道，你拥有，你知道，我网站的这一部分，所以它就像，你知道，斜杠 API 斜杠 GraphQL，就像那里的一切都由 GraphQL 拥有，然后他们会做的是，它是，它只是一个，他们基本上会为你处理很多事情，所以你可以执行不同的查询，你可以要求
you know, certain pieces of information and you'll only get back that information. Um, it's really nice. Um, I highly recommend it, especially, you know, once, if you're building a website that needs to kind of fetch data in that format, like if you're building a website that needs to kind of fetch data in that format like if you're building an email server that's a that's a great example um it's definitely a good thing to learn if you're doing anything web and this company talked about their evolution from a rest api to uh graph ql what that was like and they also have a list of lessons learned. So I definitely give it a read.
你知道，某些信息，你只会得到那些信息，嗯，这真的很好，嗯，我强烈推荐它，特别是，你知道，一旦，如果你正在构建一个需要以那种格式获取数据的网站，比如如果你正在构建一个需要以那种格式获取数据的网站，比如如果你正在构建一个电子邮件服务器，那是一个很好的例子，嗯，如果你正在做任何网络相关的事情，这绝对是一个值得学习的好东西，这家公司谈论了他们从 REST API 到 GraphQL 的演变，那是什么样的，他们还有一个经验教训列表，所以我绝对会读一读。
It's pretty interesting. They've been using GraphQL for two years. So they have a lot of different experiences. They have things that they like, things they didn't like, certain packages that they were using, things like that. And so, yeah, if you're doing any web stuff,
这很有趣，他们已经使用 GraphQL 两年了，所以他们有很多不同的经验，他们有他们喜欢的东西，他们不喜欢的东西，他们正在使用的某些包，之类的东西，所以，是的，如果你正在做任何网络相关的事情，
definitely check it out. All right. I think it's time for patrick's book of the show yeah so we're gonna do something a little bit different we didn't uh um there's not too much time between last show and this show so um i have to admit i haven't been doing much reading patrick hasn't been playing enough video games so patrick's gonna handle the book of this show and i'll do the total show uh yeah so with the thanksgiving holiday i just didn't end up uh commuting as much and so as i've attested before i call it reading but i actually mostly listen to the books uh and so i instead
一定要去看看，好的，我想是时候聊 Patrick 的节目书籍了，是的，所以我们要稍微做点不同的事情，我们没有，嗯，上期节目和这期节目之间没有太多时间，所以，嗯，我得承认我没怎么读书，Patrick 没玩够电子游戏，所以 Patrick 将处理这期节目的书，我会做总节目，是的，所以随着感恩节假期，我最终没有通勤那么多，所以正如我之前证明的那样，我称之为阅读，但我实际上大多是听书，所以我反而
was using a different book over the thanksgiving break and i decided hey this would be good to talk about on programming throwdown because it's very programming related and that is a cookbook uh that was sarcasm that's nothing to do with programming uh this book is the food lab by kenji i don't actually know how you say his last name i guess it's lopez alt but um i know him from know him i read about him when he he writes for a website called serious eats and although there have been more nerdy food websites that have been around in the past this one is like a good balance of uh sort of like nerdy tech approach to doing things without it being a gimmick and so he just takes like a more what i would say like an engineer style approach to how to cook where you'll see things like in traditional
在感恩节假期期间使用了另一本书，我决定嘿，这在 Programming Throwdown 上谈论会很好，因为它与编程非常相关，那是一本食谱，那是讽刺，那与编程无关，这本书是 Kenji 的《食物实验室》，我实际上不知道你怎么说他的姓，我猜是 Lopez Alt，但，嗯，我从知道他，我读过关于他的文章，当他为一家叫 Serious Eats 的网站写作时，虽然过去有更多书呆子气的食物网站，但这一个就像是某种书呆子技术方法来做事情的良好平衡，而不会成为噱头，所以他只是采取了，我会说像工程师风格的方法来烹饪，你会看到像在传统
french uh if you ever watched a lot of engineers talk about good eats which was alton brown's food network tv show where they kind of play the science of cooking that's sort of like that like oh in traditional French tradition, traditional French tradition. Oh man, I'm really out of it. You're not supposed to wash mushrooms under running water because they would absorb too much of the water. And so you're supposed to use this dry brush
法国，如果你看过很多工程师谈论 Good Eats，那是 Alton Brown 的 Food Network 电视节目，他们有点玩烹饪科学，那有点像那样，哦，在传统法国传统中，传统法国传统，哦天哪，我真的不在状态，你不应该在流水下清洗蘑菇，因为它们会吸收太多的水，所以你应该使用这种干刷
and you really scrub at them to get the dirt out because mushrooms are really dirty. But then like, is that true? Like that's easy to test. Just dump a bunch of mushrooms in a bucket of water for a while and then put them on a scale and see if they got heavier and if they didn't get much heavier then they're not absorbing water um but those things are i don't how would you say that those things are not even like acceptable to question because that's how people have done it for hundreds of years if you're adhering to taboo high like high cuisine yeah like they're what do you mean like you do it
你真的用力刷它们以把污垢弄出来，因为蘑菇真的很脏，但后来，那是真的吗？这很容易测试，只要把一堆蘑菇扔进一桶水里一会儿，然后把它们放在秤上，看看它们是否变重了，如果它们没有变重很多，那么它们就没有吸收水，嗯，但那些事情是，我不知道你怎么说那些事情甚至不像是可以质疑的，因为那是人们几百年来一直这样做的方式，如果你坚持禁忌，像高级烹饪，是的，就像，你的意思是什么，你这样做
because you do it and there's just no questioning of it um so one of kenji's big ones like he uses like a you know uh like what about reverse sear so if you're going to try to crisp the outside of a piece of meat tradition says you always sear it first and then braise it or whatever um so like i'm going to cook the outside really hot and then put it in a pot in the oven and cook it really low and is that better or worse than what they call the reverse here which is like cooking it low and slow and then searing it at the end um and so like it that's easy just try it both ways and then and then you know make an objective call or whatever like but people just you know kind of don't so they do this and they actually
因为你这样做，而且根本没有质疑，嗯，所以 Kenji 的大招之一，他使用像，你知道，嗯，反向煎烤怎么样？所以如果你要尝试让一块肉的外面变脆，传统说你总是先煎它，然后炖它或什么的，所以就像，我要把外面煮得很热，然后把它放在锅里放进烤箱，煮得很低，那比他们所谓的反向煎烤更好还是更差，也就是像低火慢煮，然后在最后煎它，所以就像，这很容易，只要两种方式都试一下，然后，然后你知道，做一个客观的决定或什么的，就像，但人们只是，你知道，有点不，所以他们这样做，而且他们实际上
do measurements and yeah so this food lab is sort of his approach where he tries to say like hey if you want scrambled eggs this way do it this way you want it that way do it that way like the trick isn't this or that it's just like oh add a little bit of water and your eggs are fluffy why well because the water turns to steam and when the steam is escaping it's at about the same temperature that the proteins and the eggs set and so it makes your eggs fluffy um because it sort of happens around the same temperature so if you want fluffy eggs add a little bit of water to your eggs when you scramble them um you know this is like really sort of common sense they're not really exactly food hacks but just like i i don't know i sort of relate to i feel like this is the kind of cookbook i want to be rather than this very fancy highfalutin thing
做测量，是的，所以这个“食物实验室”算是他的一种方法，他试图说，嘿，如果你想做炒蛋，就按这种方式做，如果你想那样做，就按那样做，诀窍不是这个或那个，只是像哦，加一点水，你的鸡蛋就会很蓬松，为什么呢？因为水变成了蒸汽，当蒸汽逸出时，它的温度和鸡蛋蛋白质凝固的温度差不多，所以它让你的鸡蛋变得蓬松，嗯，因为它大约在相同的温度下发生，所以如果你想要蓬松的鸡蛋，炒蛋时加一点水，嗯，你知道这真的很常识，它们并不完全是食物技巧，但我不知道，我有点感同身受，我觉得这就是我想成为的那种食谱，而不是那种非常花哨、自命不凡的东西。
where it tries to you know impress you with the you know you need the i don't want to even i don't even know how to pretend to be that you need you know one centimeter long julienned carrots and you know it's like okay great like no Yeah, no, I'd much rather have a practical book that says like, you know, here are the things you already cook. Here's how to do them better. Yeah. So then there's recipes for stuff I haven't cooked and good ideas. And I just feel like, oh, if I go do this, I'm more likely to know if it didn't work,
它试图，你知道，用你需要的那种东西来打动你，我甚至不想，我甚至不知道如何假装成那样，你需要，你知道，一厘米长的胡萝卜丝，你知道，这就像，好吧，太棒了，不，我宁愿有一本实用的书，上面写着，你知道，这些是你已经会做的菜。这是如何把它们做得更好。是的。所以还有一些我没做过的菜的食谱和好主意。我只是觉得，哦，如果我去这样做，我更有可能知道如果它没成功，
that it was something I did rather than this is a bad recipe. So anyways, yeah. So that's the Food Lab by Kenji Lopez-Alt. And we'll have a link in the show notes. And similarly to the stack sort we were talking about earlier, I do find myself and my family, the internet is sort of weird for recipes because you just go to Google and you say like, you know, French toast. And then you can find just whatever website appears
那是我做错了什么，而不是这是一个糟糕的食谱。所以无论如何，是的。这就是Kenji Lopez-Alt写的《食物实验室》。我们会在节目说明中提供链接。和我们之前谈到的堆栈排序类似，我发现我和我的家人，互联网对食谱来说有点奇怪，因为你只是去谷歌搜索，然后你说，你知道，法式吐司。然后你可以找到任何出现的网站，
at the top you click it and if it looks reasonable you cook that recipe uh and then in a week you're like i like that i didn't cook everything so i go that that's basically how i cook everything oh okay but then if you like it or don't like it what do you do again the next time because if you search it again it's not guaranteed the same site will come up oh yeah i mean if it's if i cook it and i like it i I bookmark it. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
在顶部你点击它，如果它看起来合理，你就做那个食谱，嗯，然后过了一周，你会说我喜欢那个，我没有做所有东西，所以我去，这基本上就是我做所有东西的方式，哦，好吧，但如果你喜欢或不喜欢它，下次你又该怎么办？因为如果你再次搜索它，不能保证同一个网站会出现，哦，是的，我的意思是如果我做了它，我喜欢它，我就把它加入书签。好的。好的。是的。
Yeah. But anyway, so I still like cookbooks. I have a series. I might recommend. I might have a couple shows where I recommend them because I kind of enjoy cooking as a hobby, I guess. I'm not particularly great at it, and I don't do it sort of all the time. No, I think it's a great hobby. I like it as a hobby.
是的。但无论如何，我仍然喜欢食谱。我有一个系列。我可能会推荐。我可能会有几个节目推荐它们，因为我想我把烹饪当作一种爱好。我并不是特别擅长，而且我不是一直都在做。不，我认为这是一个很棒的爱好。我喜欢把它当作一种爱好。
Yeah, it's fun. It's something you have to do anyways, so you might as well make a hobby out of it sure yeah so that's my book of the show very cool all right my tool of the show my tool of the show is uh is actually software raid controller or just using raid in general so uh quick story um about or no, I guess it was about a week ago. Um, I, you know, turned on my, my, uh, computer that I have sitting behind the TV in the living room. And, um, it told me that one of my hard drives failed and sure enough, it just completely failed.
是的，这很有趣。反正这是你必须做的事情，所以你不如把它变成一种爱好，当然，是的，这就是我的节目推荐书，非常酷，好的，我的节目推荐工具，我的节目推荐工具是，嗯，实际上是软件RAID控制器，或者只是通常使用RAID，所以，嗯，快速讲个故事，嗯，关于，或者不，我想大约是一周前。嗯，我，你知道，打开了我放在客厅电视后面的电脑。而且，嗯，它告诉我我的一个硬盘坏了，果然，它完全坏了。
Like no warning. Uh, actually my wife told me about a few weeks ago ago that it was she was hearing this kind of clicking sound coming from the computer so there was a little bit of a warning but um uh but then it went away and then all of a sudden just yeah the hard drive just spontaneously died uh fortunately i had a raid one backup and so what that means is i actually had two two terabyte hard drives that were raid one they. They were mirrored. So every time I would write a byte to one, it would write to the other one.
就像没有警告一样。嗯，实际上我妻子几周前告诉我，她听到电脑里发出这种咔哒声，所以有一点警告，但是，嗯，但后来声音消失了，然后突然之间，是的，硬盘就自发地死了，幸运的是，我有一个RAID 1备份，这意味着我实际上有两个2TB的硬盘，它们是RAID 1，它们是镜像的。所以每次我向一个写入字节时，它也会写入另一个。
And it's done automatically. So basically, the way this happens, I don't know how this works on Windows or OS X or anything like that, but on Linux, you actually, all of your hardware is in the slash dev directory. So anything in slash dev is of your hardware is in the slash dev directory. So anything in slash dev is not of your hard drive or of your, I guess, file system, is not a file.
而且它是自动完成的。所以基本上，这种情况发生的方式，我不知道这在Windows或OS X或任何类似系统上是如何工作的，但在Linux上，你实际上，你所有的硬件都在/dev目录下。所以/dev里的任何东西，你的硬件都在/dev目录下。所以/dev里的任何东西，不是你的硬盘或你的，我猜，文件系统，不是一个文件。
It's an actual pointer to some type of device or some type of engine, like dev random or something, right? So your hard drives might look something like dev slash sda, dev slash sdb for your second order, sdc, so on and so forth, right? What the RAID controller does is it makes a new device. I think mine's called dev slash md0. And when I, you know, mount that device, it, you know, looks and feels just like a hard drive. So I can, you know, mount that device, it, you know, looks and feels just like a hard drive. So I can, you know, mount it to a folder. I can open it up.
它实际上是指向某种设备或某种引擎的指针，比如dev random之类的，对吧？所以你的硬盘可能看起来像dev/sda，dev/sdb是你的第二个，sdc，以此类推，对吧？RAID控制器所做的是它创建了一个新设备。我想我的叫dev/md0。当我，你知道，挂载那个设备时，它，你知道，看起来和感觉就像一个硬盘。所以我可以，你知道，挂载那个设备，它，你知道，看起来和感觉就像一个硬盘。所以我可以，你知道，把它挂载到一个文件夹。我可以打开它。
I can add files to it, et cetera, et cetera. But everything I do actually gets written to this RAID controller, which then writes it to both of the hard drives. And so you can, you know, check the file system for errors and stuff like that just like a normal um file system and under the hood they're they're doing everything basically twice right so um so yeah i had raid i've had raid one set up for years and years and uh yeah i chose last week for one of the hard drives to just completely bite the dust and i have um almost all my family photos on that rate array so you know if I didn't have a rate array they would have just been gone I mean I probably have some on Google or something but definitely the original copies you know the original size would have been just gone so I highly highly
我可以向它添加文件，等等，等等。但我所做的一切实际上都被写入了这个RAID控制器，然后它将其写入两个硬盘。所以你可以，你知道，检查文件系统是否有错误之类的，就像一个普通的文件系统一样，在底层，它们基本上把所有事情都做了两次，对吧？所以，嗯，所以是的，我有RAID，我已经设置RAID 1很多年了，而且，是的，我上周选择让其中一个硬盘彻底报废，而且我，嗯，几乎所有的家庭照片都在那个RAID阵列上，所以你知道，如果我没有RAID阵列，它们就消失了，我的意思是，我可能在谷歌上有一些之类的，但绝对是原始副本，你知道，原始大小就彻底消失了，所以我强烈，强烈
recommend doing this if you don't have a Linux machine and you don't want to go to the trouble of setting this up, you can install, you can buy one of these NAS devices. So there's a Symbology is one, Drobo is another one. And what they'll do is they basically run the RAID controller and everything for you. So you buy this box, it's running Linux. You can just put as many hard drives as you want in it, and then you can access it from other computers in your house. So it just stays on all day. And from your desktop, you can go to some network drive and set that up.
推荐这样做，如果你没有Linux机器，也不想费心去设置这个，你可以安装，你可以买这些NAS设备之一。所以有一个Synology是一个，Drobo是另一个。它们所做的是它们基本上为你运行RAID控制器和所有东西。所以你买了这个盒子，它运行的是Linux。你可以随心所欲地放入尽可能多的硬盘，然后你可以从家里的其他电脑访问它。所以它整天开着。从你的桌面，你可以去某个网络驱动器并设置它。
In my case, I already have a computer that's running all day, just sitting behind the TV. So I set up my own. But either way, yeah, I highly recommend setting up a RAID array. There's RAID 1, which is total mirroring. So you basically end up with half the capacity. If you have more than two hard drives, you can do some of the other things like there's RAID 5, RAID 6, so on and so forth. Basically, I think the idea is that, you know, as long as you have N hard drives, you can lose one of them. Like the RAID 5 is set up so that you can lose one. And as long as you don't lose another one while, you know, the remaining hard drives are, you know, are recovering from the loss. As long as you don't lose another one in that time, you're OK, which is, you know, it's highly unlikely you're going to lose two in a row. So, yeah, definitely set up RAID.
在我的情况下，我已经有一台整天运行的电脑，就放在电视后面。所以我设置了我自己的。但无论如何，是的，我强烈建议设置一个RAID阵列。有RAID 1，这是完全镜像。所以你基本上最终得到了一半的容量。如果你有两个以上的硬盘，你可以做一些其他的事情，比如有RAID 5，RAID 6，以此类推。基本上，我认为这个想法是，你知道，只要你有N个硬盘，你就可以丢失其中一个。比如RAID 5的设置方式是你只能丢失一个。只要你在剩余的硬盘从丢失中恢复时，没有丢失另一个，只要你在那段时间内没有丢失另一个，你就没问题，这，你知道，你连续丢失两个的可能性非常小。所以，是的，一定要设置RAID。
It really saved me. I went to Amazon. I bought a new two terabyte hard drive. When it arrived, I plugged it in where the old one was. I told my RAID controller, hey, you know, add this new device. It actually, it told me it was going to take 220 minutes to, you know, replicate. But even during that time, I could add files to the RAID array. Like it's smart enough to just work, like be completely available while it's
它真的救了我。我去了亚马逊。我买了一个新的2TB硬盘。当它到达时，我把它插在旧硬盘的位置。我告诉我的RAID控制器，嘿，你知道，添加这个新设备。它实际上，它告诉我需要220分钟来，你知道，复制。但即使在那段时间里，我也可以向RAID阵列添加文件。就像它足够聪明，可以正常工作，在复制的同时完全可用
replicating and all of that so it's pretty magical actually how it works and you know totally saved me so that's my tool to show nice also it seems brave that do you have anything like that wait the 220 minutes that's only like three hours yeah well you know I was kind of curious so yeah i mean i just i created a dummy file just to see what happened and uh yeah it was pretty dangerous but you know i live on the edge i guess okay yeah i have a something sort of similar although i will admit my uh mass the network attack storage i have is RAID-RAID inside, but I sort of use backup between my desktop and it as
以及所有这些，所以它实际上非常神奇，你知道，完全救了我，所以这就是我的节目工具，不错，看起来也很勇敢，你有什么类似的东西吗？等等，220分钟，那只有三个小时，是的，好吧，你知道，我有点好奇，所以是的，我的意思是，我只是创建了一个虚拟文件来看看会发生什么，而且，是的，这非常危险，但你知道，我生活在边缘，我想，好的，是的，我有一些类似的东西，虽然我承认我的NAS，网络附加存储，里面是RAID，但我有点在我的桌面和它之间使用备份作为
the backup strategy, I guess. So I don't have like... My individual computers aren't RAIDed. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, that's true. My desktop isn't RAIDed. The only thing I have RAIDed is the family photos. Okay. And yeah, I also have that
备份策略，我想。所以我没有像……我的个人电脑没有做RAID。是的，这很有道理。是的，这是真的。我的桌面没有做RAID。我唯一做RAID的是家庭照片。好的。而且，是的，我也有那个
backed up. And I assumed my NAS was hardware RAID, but it could be software RAID. You know, yeah, I don't think hardware RAID is a thing anymore. Oh, really? Because yeah, I was thinking about this. Like I remember in like early 2000s
备份了。我以为我的NAS是硬件RAID，但它可能是软件RAID。你知道，是的，我不认为硬件RAID现在还存在。哦，真的吗？因为是的，我在想这个。就像我记得在2000年代初
when you could get a hardware RAID motherboard. But nowadays, you know, the RAID uses such a trivial amount of CPU because of moore's law and all that i don't think you can even get a hardware raid i mean or if you can it's like for some super industrial setting i will defer to you anyways all right all right um well that's my tool of the show we uh we typically uh do a pitch for audible you like like to support the show we didn't recommend a book on audible this week but we have a history on the website of many books which are available on
当你能买到硬件RAID主板时。但现在，你知道，由于摩尔定律等等，RAID使用的CPU非常少，我不认为你甚至能买到硬件RAID，我的意思是，或者如果你能买到，那也是针对某些超级工业环境的，我会听从你的意见，无论如何，好的，好的，嗯，那是我的节目工具，我们，嗯，通常，嗯，为Audible做一个推销，你喜欢，喜欢支持这个节目，我们这周没有在Audible上推荐书，但我们在网站上有许多书的历史，这些书在
audible and if you've never tried audible before i think both jason and i are subscribers and so we both enjoy it and pay happily for our own subscriptions but if you haven't and you would like to become an Audible member and get a free book in the process, you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown and check out one of the many, many books that they have. And like I said, look in our show notes for many recommendations we've made throughout time. Short books, long books, funny books, happy books, sad books. I think they got something of everything there. It really is
Audible上有，如果你以前从未尝试过Audible，我想Jason和我都是订阅者，所以我们都很享受它，并乐意为我们自己的订阅付费，但如果你还没有，并且你想成为Audible会员并在此过程中获得一本免费的书，你可以去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，看看他们拥有的许多，许多书中的一本。正如我所说，查看我们的节目说明，了解我们长期以来做出的许多推荐。短书，长书，有趣的书，快乐的书，悲伤的书。我想他们那里什么都有。它确实是
actually kind of overwhelming and they have sales too. Like while you're a member, you're able to get other books on a discount price. So it's a pretty good arrangement. I actually like it. Yeah, same here. I'm a big fan. If you don't want to support us on Audible, you can support us on Patreon
实际上有点让人不知所措，而且他们也有促销活动。就像当你成为会员时，你可以以折扣价获得其他书。所以这是一个相当不错的安排。我真的很喜欢它。是的，我也是。我是个大粉丝。如果你不想在Audible上支持我们，你可以在Patreon上支持我们
or even if you do, you can support us on audible you can support us on patreon or even if you do you can support us on both um so patreon is pretty cool it's uh um you can give up to a dollar actually this is the last month before the christmas show um last christmas that was pretty ambitious um you know we really set out to give a gift to everybody we were able to give a gift to everyone in the u.s and canada but um we had issues shipping international like shipping overseas and so i'm going to think really hard this month about what we can do um i learned a lot we learned a lot from from last year um we have a ton of fans which is amazing but it also means that, you know, logistically, there are things that we're not experts in that we either need to get some help with.
或者即使你支持，你也可以在Audible上支持我们，你可以在Patreon上支持我们，或者即使你支持，你也可以两者都支持，嗯，所以Patreon很酷，它是，嗯，你可以捐赠最多一美元，实际上这是圣诞节节目之前的最后一个月，去年的圣诞节，那非常有野心，嗯，你知道，我们真的打算给每个人一份礼物，我们能够给美国和加拿大的每个人一份礼物，但是，嗯，我们在国际运输方面遇到了问题，比如海外运输，所以我这个月会认真考虑我们能做什么，嗯，我学到了很多，我们从去年学到了很多，我们有很多粉丝，这很棒，但也意味着，你知道，在物流方面，有些事情我们不是专家，我们需要寻求一些帮助。
We're definitely going to give out the T-shirts and all of that. We do that every year. And, you know, that's pretty easy. They drop ship for us. But I'm going to, you know, figure it out. I'm thinking, you know, anything we buy online they'll ship relatively cheaply. I don't know if we can give something
我们肯定会分发T恤和所有这些。我们每年都这样做。而且，你知道，这很容易。他们为我们代发货。但我会，你知道，弄清楚。我在想，你知道，我们在网上买的任何东西他们都会相对便宜地运送。我不知道我们今年是否能给每个人
to everybody this year, but I'm going to figure that out. Stay tuned until next time. This is the last month to sign up to be in the raffle for the t-shirts and whatever mystery prize we figure out.
东西，但我会弄清楚的。敬请期待下一次。这是注册参加T恤和我们想出的任何神秘奖品抽奖的最后一个月。
Go ahead. So go ahead. You can join. You can get a crack at the mystery prizes and you can leave. It's fine. You won't hurt our feelings. But also, while you're a Patreon subscriber, you get access to the Patreon RSS feed, which is the super fast download. Downloads way faster and you can listen to it.
继续。所以继续。你可以加入。你可以有机会获得神秘奖品，然后你可以离开。没关系。你不会伤害我们的感情。但同时，当你成为Patreon订阅者时，你可以访问Patreon RSS源，这是超级快速下载。下载速度快得多，你可以收听它。
Very reliable and all that. And you help support the show, which allows us to ultimately reach more people. Well, I think it's time for the topic of the show. Customer bug handling. This is something that is actually really hard to get right. So you think about this, you have all the code on your machine you might even be cross compiling so you might even be running linux but building something for windows or something like that i mean it could be that could be really extreme right but you have all of that information you might be able to build in debug mode you end up with this enormous binary right i mean you have
非常可靠等等。而且你帮助支持这个节目，这使我们最终能够接触到更多的人。好吧，我想是时候谈谈节目的主题了。客户错误处理。这是一件实际上很难做好的事情。所以你考虑一下，你的机器上有所有的代码，你甚至可能在交叉编译，所以你甚至可能在运行Linux，但为Windows或其他类似系统构建东西，我的意思是，这可能是非常极端的，对吧？但你拥有所有这些信息，你可能能够在调试模式下构建，你最终会得到这个巨大的二进制文件，对吧？我的意思是，你有
all of your own system libraries all of that and so that makes debugging relatively easy you can step through the debugger you can do all sorts of stuff like that the issue is what happens when you know you send your program to someone else or you deploy your website or you push a mobile app and then all of a sudden you start getting reports that, hey, it locked up, it crashed, things like that. Like, what do you do then? And it turns out that question is not trivial to answer. Actually, it's actually kind of surprising that, you know, there hasn't been just something that just has solved this for everybody seems like uh like such a fundamental problem but i guess it's just so fragmented the ecosystem that's hard to really do that yeah i mean i think not just the
你自己所有的系统库，所有这些，所以这使得调试相对容易，你可以通过调试器逐步执行，你可以做各种各样的事情，问题是当你，你知道，把你的程序发给别人，或者你部署你的网站，或者你推送一个移动应用程序，然后突然之间你开始收到报告说，嘿，它锁死了，它崩溃了，诸如此类的事情。就像，那你该怎么办？事实证明，这个问题并不容易回答。实际上，令人惊讶的是，你知道，还没有什么东西能为每个人解决这个问题，这似乎是，嗯，一个如此基本的问题，但我猜生态系统太碎片化了，很难真正做到这一点，是的，我的意思是，我认为不仅仅是
fragmentation i think that we were talking about a little bit before when we were preparing for the show but i think the scale of things matters a lot too um and so i think in a you know video game where it runs on many many many well hopefully it's a successful video game where it runs on many, many, many, well, hopefully it's a successful video game, and it runs on many, many people's computers where the individual user is, I don't want to say like low sophistication, but they're not really supposed to be helping you debug your app, right? Like it just is supposed to work. And you will almost guaranteed going to get crashes just because of the statistical like
碎片化，我认为我们在准备节目之前稍微谈过，但我认为规模问题也很重要，嗯，所以我认为在，你知道，视频游戏中，它在很多很多很多，好吧，希望它是一个成功的视频游戏，它在很多很多人的电脑上运行，其中个人用户，我不想说像低复杂性，但他们并不是真的要帮你调试你的应用程序，对吧？就像它应该工作一样。而且你几乎肯定会遇到崩溃，仅仅是因为统计学上的，比如
the number of hours your game is running an aggregate across everything is like somebody's going to drop their you know tablet or lose power on their pc while they're playing your game um that versus you know this application i write is for a very important you know customer who has 10 people who use it and it's part of a multi-million dollar business and they're very sophisticated they're very invested in helping me fix my app and if something goes wrong i'm probably coming out to their site and you know working with them um to get it you know all those the spread there is just incredibly wide yep yep so yeah so i mean it's true if you go to i mean if you if you have uh enterprise customers and you can actually go on site then uh um there's a whole lot you can do there right
你的游戏在所有东西上运行的总小时数就像有人会掉落他们的，你知道，平板电脑，或者在玩你的游戏时电脑断电，嗯，那与，你知道，我写的这个应用程序是为一个非常重要的，你知道，有10个人使用的客户，它是数百万美元业务的一部分，他们非常复杂，他们非常投入于帮助我修复我的应用程序，如果出了问题，我可能会去他们的现场，你知道，和他们一起工作，嗯，去解决它，你知道，所有这些，那里的传播范围简直太广了，是的，是的，所以是的，我的意思是，这是真的，如果你去，我的意思是，如果你有，嗯，企业客户，你可以真正去现场，那么，嗯，那里有很多你可以做的事情，对吧
but let's talk about the case in the beginning where you know you are let's say video game developer and you're sending your game out to people they're paying let's say ten dollars for it um and you're not really going to be able to fly over to their house so um one thing to do is turn on debugging symbols um you know it's one of these things, I mean, you have to pass the, you know, dash G flag in GCC and things like that. And so you might be tempted to build things in release mode. But I mean, honestly, I mean, disk space is cheap. You know, network bandwidth is not that cheap, but you can, you know, most of the time these debug symbols compress quite nicely and you one thing and it's gonna be an overall theme for this show is you don't want to put yourself in a position where you can't debug the problem like you really don't you you
但让我们谈谈开始的情况，你知道，你是，比如说视频游戏开发者，你把你的游戏发给人们，他们支付，比如说十美元，而且你真的不能飞到他们家里，所以，嗯，要做的一件事是打开调试符号，你知道，这是这些事情之一，我的意思是，你必须传递，你知道，GCC中的-G标志之类的。所以你可能想在发布模式下构建东西。但我的意思是，老实说，我的意思是，磁盘空间很便宜。你知道，网络带宽没那么便宜，但你可以，你知道，大多数时候这些调试符号压缩得很好，你有一件事，这将是这个节目的一个总体主题，你不想让自己处于无法调试问题的境地，就像你真的不想，你
absolutely don't want to um you know push out a release binary you get a bunch of crash reports that you can't really do anything with, and then decide, okay, now I'm going to, you know, take out some of these optimizations, right? I mean, you can build with debug symbols and the opt mode, and it's not going to be that much slower. I will caveat that a little by saying that, in the start here, we're going to talk about a bunch of things as sort of a survey of topics. But we talked about this when we talked about don't roll your own encryption, that some of these things can have implications that are kind of big.
绝对不想，嗯，你知道，推送一个发布二进制文件，你得到了一堆你无法真正处理的崩溃报告，然后决定，好吧，现在我要，你知道，去掉一些这些优化，对吧？我的意思是，你可以用调试符号和优化模式构建，它不会慢那么多。我会稍微警告一下，在开始这里，我们将讨论一堆作为主题调查的事情。但当我们谈论不要自己编写加密时，我们谈到了这一点，其中一些事情可能会产生相当大的影响。
So turning on debug symbols is very helpful when you're debugging, but you have to weigh the cost of people understanding more about your code. So if you're in something where you're distributing code that you don't want people to know what it does, or it has secret sauce in it, or a really great filter or whatever, which is not most people, admittedly. But there are certain cases where you're going to want to be very careful about, I give this to someone, but I want to limit their ability to understand exactly how it works. Yeah, you know, that's a really good point.
所以打开调试符号在调试时非常有帮助，但你必须权衡人们更多地了解你的代码的成本。所以如果你处于某种情况，你正在分发你不希望人们知道它做什么的代码，或者它里面有秘密配方，或者一个非常好的过滤器之类的，这并不是大多数人，诚然。但在某些情况下，你会想要非常小心，我把它给了某人，但我想要限制他们准确理解它是如何工作的能力。是的，你知道，这是一个非常好的观点。
I hadn't really thought about that. But I guess what you could do in that case is you could have, you know, basically you could divide your code up into the secure code and the unsecure code. And, you know, the secure code could be built without debug symbols and then as a static library and then just linked in to the unsecure code. But yeah, I mean, generally, unless, yeah, if it's a secret sauce, you can, there's ways around that, but generally you want to.
我真的没想过那个。但我猜在这种情况下你可以做的是你可以有，你知道，基本上你可以把你的代码分成安全代码和不安全代码。而且，你知道，安全代码可以在没有调试符号的情况下构建，作为静态库，然后链接到不安全代码中。但是的，我的意思是，通常，除非，是的，如果是秘密配方，你可以，有办法绕过它，但通常你想要。
Just be careful. Yeah, and I think most of the time, the errors are typically in the interface, in the high level part of the code, which is not, it doesn't generally have a lot of IP. Yeah, the other part is, you know, you have logs. If you can, you want to leave those logs running. Ideally, you want, if you're using like G log or easy logging, in the case of C++, or using like Bunyan, if you're using JavaScript, any of these log tools,
只是要小心。是的，而且我认为大多数时候，错误通常出现在接口中，在代码的高级部分，这并不是，它通常没有很多知识产权。是的，另一部分是，你知道，你有日志。如果可以的话，你想让那些日志保持运行。理想情况下，你想要，如果你正在使用像G log或easy logging，在C++的情况下，或者使用像Bunyan，如果你正在使用JavaScript，任何这些日志工具，
they all have log levels, even like the log4j, if you're using Java. And you typically want to allow people to turn on verbose logging. So you can have some kind of configuration file. And when they set verbose to one you know they get all the verbose log and and then they can you know email that to you you could have a button where when there's a crash you know you it automatically emails the logs things like that
它们都有日志级别，甚至像log4j，如果你正在使用Java。而且你通常想要允许人们打开详细日志记录。所以你可以有某种配置文件。当他们把verbose设置为1时，你知道，他们会得到所有的详细日志，然后他们可以，你知道，通过电子邮件发给你，你可以有一个按钮，当有崩溃时，你知道，它会自动通过电子邮件发送日志，诸如此类
but basically you want to have access to that information that you have when you're debugging. That's another way to think about it is, is if you don't have something when you're debugging, can you still triage the problem? If the answer is no, then you have to kind of plan for that, right? You have to assume that whatever crashes you're seeing, you're going to see similar crashes coming from other people. So for example, when we were rolling out the first versions of the Eternal Terminal, we were getting tons of really bizarre crashes because it was running on Windows for Linux, it was running on BSD, there's people. So we had deployed it at the place where I work, and there was pretty quickly, there was hundreds of people using it.
但基本上你想要访问你在调试时拥有的那些信息。这是另一种思考方式，就是如果你在调试时没有某些东西，你还能对问题进行分类吗？如果答案是否定的，那么你必须为此做好计划，对吧？你必须假设你看到的任何崩溃，你都会看到来自其他人的类似崩溃。例如，当我们推出Eternal Terminal的第一个版本时，我们遇到了大量非常奇怪的崩溃，因为它在Windows for Linux上运行，它在BSD上运行，有人。所以我们在我工作的地方部署了它，很快就有数百人在使用它。
And we just encountered tons of OS-specific bugs that were, like, extremely difficult for us to triage because we didn't have any logs. We didn't have really any of the stack trace, any of the debug symbols turned on. And since then, you know, we've kind of added all this, any of the debug symbols turned on. Since then, we've kind of added all this capability. It's made a big difference.
我们只是遇到了大量的操作系统特定错误，这些错误，就像，对我们来说极其难以分类，因为我们没有任何日志。我们真的没有任何堆栈跟踪，没有任何打开的调试符号。从那时起，你知道，我们已经添加了所有这些，没有任何打开的调试符号。从那时起，你知道，我们已经添加了所有这些功能。这产生了很大的不同。
I think with both... With both rolling logs and log levels, there's consideration. On rolling logs, one of the things is you want to limit how much space you take up, but you need enough logs so that if something starts dumping tons of things going wrong you don't miss the thing that started at all and instead only see the the symptoms which
我认为对于滚动日志和日志级别，都有考虑。关于滚动日志，其中一件事是你想要限制你占用的空间，但你需要足够的日志，以便如果某些东西开始倾倒大量出错的东西，你不会错过开始的那件事，而是只看到症状，这
is a problem i run into other things there you can be clever about is trying to be careful about how many of a given kind of error you're seeing so often you start spitting off the same kind of error over and over again and oftentimes it's the first one that's the most interesting and so making sure you always capture like the first of a given kind of error over and over again. And oftentimes, it's the first one that's the most interesting. And so making sure you always capture like the first of a given kind of error, like sort of slightly smarter ways. And with log levels, being careful that logging has some cost, spending time driving down that cost is important. And then making sure that you're not logging at such a high rate or in a part of code that is running at a high frequency that you end up costing a lot of computation time to do the actual logging yep yeah it totally makes sense yeah this is something that you know definitely before you ship a binary you want to run it in
是我在其他事情中遇到的问题，你可以聪明一点，小心你看到的某种错误的数量，所以通常你开始一遍又一遍地吐出同一种错误，而且通常第一个是最有趣的，所以确保你总是捕获像同一种错误的第一个，一遍又一遍。而且通常，第一个是最有趣的。所以确保你总是捕获像同一种错误的第一个，比如稍微聪明一点的方法。而且对于日志级别，要小心日志记录有一些成本，花时间降低该成本很重要。然后确保你没有以如此高的速率记录，或者在以高频率运行的代码部分中记录，以至于你最终花费了大量的计算时间来进行实际的日志记录，是的，是的，这完全有道理，是的，这是你，你知道，在发布二进制文件之前肯定想要在
verbose mode and just make sure that it isn't just completely blowing up the logs because that can happen very easily. If you put a log inside some really tight for loop, just one log line can cause, you know, just megabytes and megabytes of log to just start building up almost as fast as you can see it. Another thing is, you know, definitely, you know, handle crashes and things like that pretty gracefully.
详细模式下运行它，并确保它不仅仅是完全炸毁日志，因为这很容易发生。如果你把一个日志放在某个非常紧密的for循环中，仅仅一行日志就可以导致，你知道，仅仅几兆字节和几兆字节的日志开始积累，几乎和你看到的一样快。另一件事是，你知道，肯定，你知道，优雅地处理崩溃之类的事情。
There's a bunch of libraries to help with this, but basically you want to catch the crash. And typically what will happen is you'll try to get the stack trace. So in the case of Linux, there's actually a system call called backtrace that will give you the function pointers of the whole stack up until
有一堆库可以帮助解决这个问题，但基本上你想要捕获崩溃。通常会发生的是你会尝试获取堆栈跟踪。所以在Linux的情况下，实际上有一个系统调用叫backtrace，它会给你整个堆栈的函数指针，直到
where you are right now. And so you'll want to, you know, run backtrace and then, you know, dump that to a disk to file or something or to a log or something like that. In addition to crashes, I mean, crashes is the most common thing that, you know, you'll want to handle. But also there are signals. So so for example if you divide by zero um well depending on the programming language but i think in c you might get an exception but i'm sorry in c++ you might get an exception but if you divide by zero and c you're not going to get some type of exception there isn't even a concept of that you're going to get what's called a signal um and you can look up uh the different signals there's sig abort there's uh sig sev um and and you what you want to do is look up all
你现在所在的地方。所以你会想要，你知道，运行backtrace，然后，你知道，把它转储到磁盘到文件或类似的东西，或者到日志或类似的东西。除了崩溃，我的意思是，崩溃是你，你知道，想要处理的最常见的事情。但也有信号。所以，例如，如果你除以零，嗯，取决于编程语言，但我认为在C中你可能会得到一个异常，但我很抱歉，在C++中你可能会得到一个异常，但如果你除以零，在C中你不会得到某种异常，甚至没有那个概念，你会得到所谓的信号，而且你可以查找，嗯，不同的信号，有sig abort，有，嗯，sig sev，而且，而且你想要做的是查找所有
these different signals and make sure you're handling them uh gracefully like some of them like sig interrupt you don't really want to handle because that's only for when you're debugging or if someone hits ctrl c on your program maybe just leave it up to them. But you know, definitely the big ones like sig abort, you know, sig sev and maybe sig term when the process, when something external tells your process to terminate. You want to handle those and catch those. And again, write a log out really quick or something like that. So then on the other end,
这些不同的信号，并确保你正在优雅地处理它们，嗯，其中一些，比如sig interrupt，你真的不想处理，因为那只是为了当你调试时，或者如果有人在你的程序上按ctrl c，也许只是留给他们。但是，你知道，肯定是大信号，比如sig abort，你知道，sig sev，也许还有sig term，当进程，当外部的东西告诉你的进程终止时。你想要处理那些并捕获那些。而且再次，快速写出一个日志或类似的东西。所以然后在另一端，
now you've dumped all these logs. You have some way of getting these logs to some server that you own. Maybe use GraphQL for that or something else. And now you have to process all of those logs, right? And you don't want to be especially if you have you know let's say 20 or 30 bug reports which you feel like are the same bug you want to be very efficient at sort of going through those logs and picking out the most important pieces maybe you
现在你已经转储了所有这些日志。你有某种方法把这些日志传送到你拥有的某个服务器。也许为此使用GraphQL或其他东西。现在你必须处理所有这些日志，对吧？而且你不想，特别是如果你有，你知道，比如说20或30个你觉得是同一个错误的错误报告，你想要非常高效地，你知道，浏览这些日志并挑选出最重要的部分，也许你
even want to write something that will pull the stack trace and dump it to a database you just have a database full of stack traces. And so this, I think we've talked about this many times, but become an expert in grep. Grep will absolutely save you. Grep is basically a way for you to just, you know, search for specific words and files. If you're your stack trace,
甚至想要写一些东西来提取堆栈跟踪并将其转储到数据库，你只是有一个装满堆栈跟踪的数据库。所以这个，我想我们已经谈过很多次了，但要成为grep的专家。Grep绝对会救你。Grep基本上是你，你知道，搜索文件中的特定单词的一种方式。如果你的堆栈跟踪，
log line starts with stack trace colon, you could grep for stack trace colon, and you'll just see all of the stack traces and all of your logs. It's getting more common now to actually write logs as JSON objects. So like Bunyan does JSON. A lot of people now are starting to use JSON. And so you could use JQ, which stands for JSON query. And it's similar to grep in the sense that you can say, you know, just fetch this one object inside of this JSON object if it exists.
日志行以stack trace冒号开头，你可以grep stack trace冒号，你就会看到所有的堆栈跟踪和你所有的日志。现在实际上把日志写成JSON对象变得越来越普遍了。所以像Bunyan做JSON。现在很多人开始使用JSON。所以你可以使用JQ，它代表JSON query。它类似于grep，因为你可以说，你知道，如果存在，只获取这个JSON对象里面的这一个对象。
Or you could say, you know, give me all of the keys that start with this. And so it definitely becomes proficient with JQ. The other part that's really important is, you know, when you get the, you know, again, the people who are running your code, they don't have your code most of the time, right? So they're running your game or your app or your program, but they don't have the original source code, right? But when there's a crash, you want to know the line of the source code so that you can debug, right? So what you have instead are you have these pointers,
或者你可以说，你知道，给我所有以这个开头的键。所以它肯定会变得精通JQ。另一部分非常重要，你知道，当你得到，你知道，再次，运行你的代码的人，他们大多数时候没有你的代码，对吧？所以他们在运行你的游戏或你的应用程序或你的程序，但他们没有原始源代码，对吧？但当有崩溃时，你想知道源代码的行，以便你可以调试，对吧？所以你有什么，相反，你有这些指针，
these function pointer, these function addresses, and the addresses map to lines of code, right? So every function address maps to the start of a function in some source file, right? And so you can use, on Linux, it's called ADDR2LINE. On OS X, it's called ATOS. I don't actually know what it is on Windows. I'm sure there's something on Windows. No, there's not.
这些函数指针，这些函数地址，地址映射到代码行，对吧？所以每个函数地址映射到某个源文件中函数的开始，对吧？所以你可以使用，在Linux上，它叫ADDR2LINE。在OS X上，它叫ATOS。我实际上不知道它在Windows上是什么。我肯定Windows上有什么。不，没有。
Okay, yeah. But these tools, what they will do is, you know, when you run backtrace on Linux, as I said, you're going to get a list of these pointers, and you can dump them to a log, let's say in hexadecimal, right? Then on your side, when you get this stack trace, you're going to need to convert that into the lines of source code. And that's what these tools do. So these tools take in the binary and they also i think you run them from the directory that has your source code uh or maybe it's from the directory that built the binary you have to look up in the manual but basically you'll run it from
好的，是的。但这些工具，它们会做的是，你知道，当你在Linux上运行backtrace时，正如我所说，你会得到这些指针的列表，你可以把它们转储到日志中，比如说十六进制，对吧？然后在你这边，当你得到这个堆栈跟踪时，你需要把它转换成源代码行。这就是这些工具所做的。所以这些工具接收二进制文件，而且我也认为你从拥有源代码的目录运行它们，嗯，或者也许是从构建二进制文件的目录，你必须在手册中查找，但基本上你会从
a place where they know where your source code is um they know where the binary is that's another thing is when you ship the binary you're going to want to basically know, get your source control tagged. So if I ship, let's say version one, I want to tag, you know, my source control repository and say, this is version one, this is exactly what every source file looks like. And here's the version one, you know, binary. So so then if you get a crash back you can load that version one binary you can download that you can get the pointers from that from that stack trace and using this the the correct you know version of the source code and binary you can actually recover the lines um in the source where that person was when they crashed, right?
一个他们知道你的源代码在哪里，他们知道二进制文件在哪里，这是另一件事，当你运送二进制文件时，你将想要基本上知道，获取你的源代码控制标记。所以如果我运送，比如说版本一，我想要标记，你知道，我的源代码控制存储库并说，这是版本一，这就是每个源文件的样子。这是版本一，你知道，二进制文件。所以，如果你得到一个崩溃返回，你可以加载那个版本一二进制文件，你可以下载那个，你可以从那个堆栈跟踪中获取指针，并且使用正确的，你知道，版本的源代码和二进制文件，你可以实际上恢复，你知道，那个人崩溃时所在的源代码中的行，对吧？
So without this, you're going to be totally lost, right? I mean, someone's going to say, hey, my program crashed. And you'll have to kind of say, oh, what were you doing when it crashed? I mean, it's impossible, right? You don't want to do that. So with something like this, let's say, oh, my program crashed. You say, okay, give me the stack trace. And you're going to get this list of hexadecimal numbers.
所以没有这个，你将完全迷失，对吧？我的意思是，有人会说，嘿，我的程序崩溃了。你将不得不说，哦，它崩溃时你在做什么？我的意思是，这不可能，对吧？你不想那样做。所以有了这样的东西，比如说，哦，我的程序崩溃了。你说，好的，给我堆栈跟踪。你将得到这个十六进制数字列表。
And you can pipe that list into address to line. And it will actually tell you the specific lines that the person was on. And you can follow that all the way up to main. Like the furthest one will always be the int main that starts the program. So, you know, if you're running, if this is like a Python program, then you don't really have to worry about that.
你可以把那个列表管道传输到address to line。它实际上会告诉你那个人所在的特定行。你可以一直追踪到main。最远的一个总是启动程序的int main。所以，你知道，如果你正在运行，如果这是一个Python程序，那么你真的不必担心那个。
But that also means you're sort of basically kind of distributing the source code in that case, right? I think you could use something like PyFreeze, like one of these compilers um but i think even in that case it distributes a source code see i don't think there's any way around it in python um now obviously if you're giving people the source code and the binary they could you could even run address to line on their computer and then just send you the location of the crash. But for most of these languages, like even Java, you'll have to unwind the stack.
但这也意味着你基本上是在那种情况下分发源代码，对吧？我想你可以使用像PyFreeze这样的东西，像这些编译器之一，嗯，但我认为即使在这种情况下，它也会分发源代码，看，我不认为在Python中有任何绕过它的方法，嗯，现在显然如果你给人们源代码和二进制文件，你甚至可以在他们的电脑上运行address to line，然后只是把崩溃的位置发给你。但对于大多数这些语言，比如甚至Java，你将不得不解开堆栈。
And I don't think you have to use any special program in Java, but you'll have to handle that. So I think we covered, that's pretty much desktop in a nutshell. The hardest part there, as I said, is the crash handlers. There's a lot of, if you just look up GitHub C++ crash handler,
而且我不认为你必须在Java中使用任何特殊的程序，但你将不得不处理那个。所以我认为我们涵盖了，这基本上就是桌面简而言之。最困难的部分，正如我所说，是崩溃处理程序。有很多，如果你只是查找GitHub C++崩溃处理程序，
you'll find a bunch of really great libraries to help you out. And I think it's definitely something where if you're going to ship, you also want to practice it, if that makes sense. So introducing crashes and making sure that your logging is actually working as intended, because nothing's worse than a very rare crash happening and the logging isn't configured properly and you don't have what you need. Yeah, actually, I can't remember.
你会找到一堆非常好的库来帮助你。而且我认为这绝对是一件事，如果你要运送，你也想要练习它，如果这有意义的话。所以引入崩溃并确保你的日志记录实际上按预期工作，因为没有什么比发生非常罕见的崩溃而日志记录没有正确配置并且你没有你需要的东西更糟糕的了。是的，实际上，我不记得了。
Oh, I think it's Android. I don't know if it's in the modern Android, but there was definitely a version of Android, or maybe I'm mixing things up here, but there was something I saw where basically you could cause a crash like there was just like a expert menu and you could go into a developer menu developer settings and one of the developer settings was crash and and i i just you know out of morbid curiosity i tapped it and yeah it crashed and uh you definitely want something like that in the first version where you know hopefully you
哦，我想是Android。我不知道它是否在现代Android中，但肯定有一个版本的Android，或者也许我在这里混淆了事情，但我看到了一些东西，基本上你可以导致崩溃，就像有一个专家菜单，你可以进入开发者菜单开发者设置，其中一个开发者设置是崩溃，而且我，你知道，出于病态的好奇心，我点击了它，是的，它崩溃了，而且，嗯，你肯定在第一个版本中想要这样的东西，你知道，希望你
bury it where way down in the menu but um you know someone who's helping you out can go hit the crash button and you should be able to get a crash and you should be able to trace exactly the line uh that crashed and uh and and what you know functions called into that function so on and so forth so now for the web um you, if you're building a website, there's two components, your client and your server, right? The server is pretty straightforward because on the server, it's you own the code, you have the binary all in one place.
把它埋在菜单很深的地方，但是，你知道，帮助你的人可以去点击崩溃按钮，你应该能够得到一个崩溃报告，并且应该能够追踪到导致崩溃的确切代码行，以及调用该函数的函数，以此类推。现在对于网络来说，如果你正在构建一个网站，有两个组件：客户端和服务器，对吧？服务器非常简单，因为在服务器上，代码是你自己的，二进制文件都在同一个地方。
Even if you're not developing on the server, you can always push the code to the server. And so that's not really that um let's say interesting um you could even be running like a totally interpreted language like python or ruby or something um it's much more interesting when you get crashes on the browser right now this isn't you know literally crashing the browser because um that's that's always chrome's fault if you can crash the browser um you because that's always Chrome's fault. If you can crash the browser, that's pretty much on them. But if your code causes an exception, that's typically the thing you ought to watch out for.
即使你不是在服务器上开发，你也可以随时将代码推送到服务器。所以这并不是那么……怎么说呢，有趣。你甚至可以运行像 Python 或 Ruby 这样完全解释型的语言。当你遇到浏览器崩溃时，情况会更有趣。现在，这并不是说真的让浏览器崩溃，因为那总是 Chrome 的错。如果你能让浏览器崩溃，那基本上是他们的责任。但如果你的代码导致了异常，那通常是你应该注意的事情。
So for example, you're getting the mean of a list of values, but the list is empty and you divide it by zero or something like that. So in this case, your browser JavaScript will throw an exception and you have to handle that. And so typically on the website, the way this works is because the JavaScript is, because the source code of the JavaScript
例如，你正在获取一个值列表的平均值，但列表是空的，你除以了零之类的。在这种情况下，你的浏览器 JavaScript 会抛出一个异常，你必须处理它。通常在网站上，它的工作方式是，因为 JavaScript 的源代码
is sent to the browser, you don't have to worry about address to line or anything like that. One thing you do have to worry about is the demangling. So if you do, for example, you run like one of these scripts that compresses your JavaScript code, it might take out all the new lines. And then now, big surprise surprise every crash happens on line one right so so typically javascript you know when you do one of these compression tools it'll
被发送到浏览器，你不需要担心地址到代码行的映射之类的东西。你确实需要担心的一件事是名称修饰还原（demangling）。所以，如果你运行像压缩 JavaScript 代码的脚本，它可能会删掉所有的换行符。然后，惊喜惊喜，每次崩溃都发生在第一行。所以通常 JavaScript 在使用这些压缩工具时，它会
create what's called a source map which the source map basically just says you know column 40,000 to 40,030 actually maps to line 3004 you know know, and so on and so forth. And the source map is just this huge file that maps, you know, chunks of that enormous one-line JavaScript file to the original, you know, file name and line. So it's actually similar to address to line, you know, conceptually. And so there are tools which will take the JavaScript stack trace of the one line file and convert it into the appropriate stack trace that's readable.
创建一个所谓的源映射（source map），源映射基本上只是说，第 40,000 到 40,030 列实际上映射到第 3004 行，以此类推。源映射只是一个巨大的文件，它将那个巨大的单行 JavaScript 文件的片段映射到原始的文件名和行号。所以从概念上讲，它实际上类似于地址到代码行的映射。因此，有一些工具可以将单行文件的 JavaScript 堆栈跟踪转换为可读的适当堆栈跟踪。
So you have to deal with that. But basically, it's a similar idea where when there's a crash, because it's a website, you don't have to worry about how to get the crash to the server because you already have like a client server framework in place. You just use whatever you're using to send data between those two machines. So use AJAX or even WebSockets, whatever you want. But then on the server, you know, you'll have to do some work. On mobile, it's very different. So I've linked to a couple of libraries. For Android, it's ACRA.
所以你必须处理这个问题。但基本上，这是一个类似的想法，当发生崩溃时，因为它是网站，你不需要担心如何将崩溃信息发送到服务器，因为你已经有了客户端-服务器框架。你只需要使用你在两台机器之间传输数据时使用的任何东西。所以使用 AJAX 或 WebSockets，随你喜欢。但在服务器端，你需要做一些工作。在移动端，情况非常不同。所以我链接了几个库。对于 Android，是 ACRA。
And for iOS, it's KSCrash. And yeah, basically, you know, these libraries will, it's similar to, it's more similar to desktop than to web, right? So these will send um crash logs to some endpoint you know that you have to set up um sometimes they can even send it through some ios or android infrastructure and then they'll arrive in the you know developer um in the you know the developer store the developer platform or front end um you can collect these crash logs. But, you know, I think in the case of Android and iOS, it's much more handled by the actual app stores. So I know I made an Android app a while back. It's been probably six years.
对于 iOS，是 KSCrash。是的，基本上这些库更类似于桌面端而不是 Web 端，对吧？所以这些库会将崩溃日志发送到你必须设置的某个端点，有时它们甚至可以通过一些 iOS 或 Android 基础设施发送，然后它们会到达开发者平台或前端，你可以收集这些崩溃日志。但是，我认为在 Android 和 iOS 的情况下，这更多是由实际的应用商店处理的。我知道我很久以前做过一个 Android 应用，大概是六年前了。
But at that time, they had a set of, you know, crash reporting tools. So I would just get a list of crashes and they would provide the stack traces. So they would do a lot of that for you. So I think definitely take a look at what the Play Store can do, what the iOS Store can do. But here's a couple of libraries that streamline that and make it even easier.
但在那时，他们有一套崩溃报告工具。所以我只会得到一份崩溃列表，他们会提供堆栈跟踪。所以他们会为你做很多事情。所以我认为一定要看看 Play Store 和 iOS Store 能做什么。但这里有几个库可以简化这个过程，让它变得更容易。
I've not developed much on mobile, but I feel in some ways mobile might be the easiest because even though there's lots and lots of mobile devices, it feels like there's far less than the number of configurations of computer hardware or web browser configurations. And so I feel like the number of your ability to potentially be able to replicate the issue might be much higher. Yeah, that's a really good point.
我没有在移动端开发太多，但我觉得在某些方面移动端可能是最简单的，因为尽管有很多很多的移动设备，但感觉它们比计算机硬件配置或 Web 浏览器配置的数量要少得多。所以我感觉你能够重现问题的可能性可能会高得多。是的，这是一个很好的观点。
There is, let me see if I can find it. There's a really good tool which simulates different browsers. I won't look it up now in the interest of time. But if you kind of Google around for, I think it's called like a browser simulator. But basically, literally on the left-hand side, it has a panel and you can choose like Chrome, Firefox. I'm sure it can't simulate everything because it's just trying to run your JavaScript kind of through this middleware layer.
有一个，让我看看能不能找到它。有一个非常好的工具可以模拟不同的浏览器。为了节省时间，我现在就不查了。但如果你搜索一下，我想它叫浏览器模拟器之类的。但基本上，在左侧有一个面板，你可以选择 Chrome、Firefox。我敢肯定它不能模拟所有东西，因为它只是试图通过这个中间件层运行你的 JavaScript。
It's not literally executing different browser code. But it'll try its best to, at least for CSS and things like that, catch a lot of those issues. But yeah, you're right. I mean, browser is in a sense the worst, although things are kind of homogenizing now where I think Chrome, you know, Brave, Firefox, you know, most things now are kind of pretty cross platform. Cool. Cool. Yeah, definitely.
它并不是真的在执行不同的浏览器代码。但它会尽力而为，至少对于 CSS 之类的东西，捕捉到很多这类问题。但你是对的，浏览器在某种意义上是最糟糕的，尽管现在情况正在趋于同质化，我认为 Chrome、Brave、Firefox，大多数东西现在都相当跨平台了。酷，酷。是的，绝对是。
Send us your worst debugging nightmare where someone has a crash and there's absolutely no way to replicate. We always love hearing stories like that. I've definitely caused more than a few of those myself. This is why it's what inspired this episode. And hopefully with these tips, you can kind of avoid doing it. You could set people up where if they have a crash, they can send you some information. You'd be able to triage.
把你们最糟糕的调试噩梦发给我们，就是那种有人崩溃但完全无法重现的情况。我们总是喜欢听这样的故事。我自己肯定也造成过不少这样的情况。这就是激发这一集灵感的原因。希望通过这些技巧，你可以避免这样做。你可以设置一些机制，如果他们遇到崩溃，他们可以发送一些信息给你。你就能进行分类处理。
One thing, definitely expect everything to crash. Like if you whatever you write, you have to have some way to handle crashes either as patrick said because of different um clients software um sometimes there's people who are running you know windows xp and you'd be amazed like even the simplest programs don't work um people just do things you don't expect there's situation you don't expect there's internet um um like internet like some people's internet connection are not as reliable and um you know it's very very hard to plan for all of these things so you definitely expect failure and uh have the right way of like ideally automatically just just sending some information to you cool that's pretty much all i have. All right. Until next time. All right. Next time is the Christmas show.
有一件事，一定要预料到一切都会崩溃。无论你写什么，你都必须有某种方式来处理崩溃，正如 Patrick 所说，因为不同的客户端软件，有时有人在运行 Windows XP，你会惊讶地发现，即使是最简单的程序也无法运行。人们会做你意想不到的事情，有你意想不到的情况，还有互联网，有些人的互联网连接并不那么可靠，而且很难为所有这些事情做计划。所以一定要预料到失败，并有正确的方式，理想情况下是自动地将一些信息发送给你。酷，我基本上就这些了。好的，下次见。好的，下次是圣诞节目。
And actually, for January, we have a special guest. This might be our... Hopefully. Hopefully. Hopefully. Nothing against... Yeah, yeah, that's true. Actually, I won't spoil it. I won't spoil it. But we have an amazing guest. Yeah, hopefully. And I'm really excited.
实际上，对于一月，我们有一位特别嘉宾。这可能是我们的……希望如此。希望如此。希望如此。并不是针对……是的，是的，那是真的。实际上，我不会剧透的。我不会剧透的。但我们有一位很棒的嘉宾。是的，希望如此。我真的很兴奋。
Definitely, it's going to be absolutely phenomenal. We're going to start the year off extremely special way. But next month, we're going to have our Christmas giveaway or holiday giveaway. And, you know, hopefully give out some really cool T-shirts and some other prizes. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution share-alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work,
绝对的，这绝对会非常精彩。我们将以一种非常特别的方式开始新的一年。但下个月，我们将进行圣诞赠品或节日赠品活动。希望送出一些很酷的 T 恤和其他奖品。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，
to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。